salut a tous une énigme par jour pendant
32 jours d'abord je vous donne la
solution d'hier et ensuite l'énigme du
jour solutions d'hier
attention si vous n'avez pas regardé la
vidéo d'hier allait voir les nîmes avant
la réponse et 24 1862 je vous laisse
vérifier en regardant la vidéo d'hier
tout les prémices sont bonnes la seule
solution possible ses 24 1862 ne nous
attardons pas et passons à l'énigme
d'aujourd'hui énigmes numéro 23 c'est
l'énigme 2 l'escarbot c'était un
escargot que si tu veux vous faire ce
pathétique c'est l'histoire d'un
escargot qui veut grimper au sommet d'un
mur de dix mètres mais il se déplace
très bizarrement notre escargots la
journée il arrive à monter trois mètres
mais durant la nuit avec le froid et
l'humidité il redescend de 2 m en
partant du principe qu'il va commencer à
grimper le mur de tout en bas un matin
combien de jours il lui faudra pour
atteindre le sommet du mur donc les 10 m
vous pouvez soit mettre ça sur une
feuille de papier pour essayer de
trouver plus facilement ou alors dressé
un escargot
c'est possible mais c'est long pour la
réponse sachant que je la donnerai
toutes manières demain à 11 heures et
vous aider vous avez trouvé n'oubliez
pas de mettre un pouce en l'air pour
qu'on sache le nombre de personnes qui
ont réussi à résoudre cette énigme ou
alors qu'ils la connaissent et peut-être
et dans les vidéos il n'y a pas besoin
de parcourir 10 mètres pour trouver le
bouton pour s'abonner il ya sur le logo
ici ou juste sous la vidéo donc pensez à
vous abonner avant de partir et rendez
vous demain à 11 heures dimanche matin
de 11h ciao